bonjour benjamin morel merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
première question que pensez vous de
cette grande promotion
alors on a malgré tout des promus dont
on ne peut pas soupçonner de serre et le
pourquoi de la commission après ce que
vous avez montré là je serais tenté de
dire elle sans doute malheureusement et
il s'appelle manière assez classique en
été vous savez quand apple ont créé la
légende et l'invs il parle des rochers
parce que à l'époque il s'agit il s'est
dit toujours 2 à travers cet instrument
il y a suscité à travers la vanité une
forme d'adhésion et de soutien alors à
travers l'émulation à la nation et aux
côtés de la nation évidemment mais
également au gouvernement en place
et cette légion d'honneur elle a donné
lieu dans le passé à plusieurs scandales
à nombre de scandales pour des copinages
1 le scandale cdeps évidemment en 1887
qui conduit à la démission du président
de la république d'alors du télévie
parce que son gendre vend des déductions
d'honneur on a eu un deuxième gros
scandale en 1926 et récemment avec des
affaires comme celle de maistre et
cetera on a connu ce type de scandale
qui ont conduite soit des démissions
soit à des soies des retrait de la
légion d'honneur
là en l'occurrence on a en effet une
sorte de renvoi d'ascenseur
c'est ma foi est assez malheureusement
assez connu assez classique
alors philippe g 20 ont été écartés de
la légion d'honneur il aurait été
contacté puis finalement le gouvernement
à ses volte face est ce que ça vous
étonne alors il faut voir que la légion
d'honneur elle il faut que quelqu'un
d'aussi propose donc est-ce que
philippe juvin a été contacté par
quelqu'un qui voulait le proposer et
finalement le président de la république
qui demeurent maîtres du de l'ordre de
la légion d'honneur à refuser cette
candidature il faudrait voir par thil
été contactés se doute qu'il a été
contacté par emmanuel macron
historiquement il faut bien comprendre
que la légion d'honneur est confiée aux
mains du président de la république en
tant que grand maître de l'ordre de la
légion d'honneur au début de la
troisième république quand on pense
qu'on va rétablir la monarchie
donc on voit dans le président une sorte
d'institution assez neutre un petit peu
une monarchie constitutionnelle à la
britannique est donc ce côté un petit
peu double face du président de la vème
république est à la fois très politique
et qui en même temps gars est au ras du
président un peu neutre et cetera du
début de la troisième
conduit à une forme de confusion et en
effet on peut interroger quelque peu ce
qu'a donc est-ce que c'était étonnant
qu'il était proposée non est-ce que
c'était tôt est-ce que c'est étonnant
qu'il ait été refusée au vu des
positions assez durs qu'ils adoptent
aujourd'hui vous avez du gouvernement
c'est non plus plus généralement pour
parler de la communication du
gouvernement en cette période de crise
sanitaire
on a que vous aviez bertron au président
des dépôts de france qui a dénoncé
aujourd'hui la cacophonie
institutionnalisé de la communication
gouvernementale sur la vaccination à
contres locaux vides 19 qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
alors on peut discuter je suis pas
specialities publique sanitaire de la
stratégie de vaccination
probablement que le procès qu'on fait
l'administration française est un procès
injuste les responsabilités en la
matière sont des responsabilités
politiques et l'administration a suivi
des consignes politiques qui a une forme
de défaut sage sur l'administration
là où en revanche il y a un problème qui
est certain c'est en effet au niveau de
la communication la communication était
du gouvernement concernant la
vaccination a été totalement erratique
et elle a conduit en voulant débrancher
quelque peu la défiance de certains anti
vaccins a au contraire l'accroître et a
donné par ailleurs un sentiment dîner
festivités les politiques
donc vous avez là un problème qui est un
problème majeur 2
communication qui est beaucoup plus que
la stratégie vaccinale probablement
coûté au gouvernement sur le très très
long terme
benjamin morel merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur rt france